ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show here with newly married ben
avery you finally did it you made it
legal with the old battle axe
and now a long happy life together
uh recap of the wedding which was lovely
is on uh patreon
and um i had a great time i enjoyed it i
really did truly everyone loved it
i liked it um and and even the parts of
it i didn't know that i would think i
would enjoy
um like the exorcism for example they
did an exorcism where they brought a
child out in a tub
and they kept putting it in the water
and then there was a lot of screaming
but then your mother said that's how it
you know it's working it's the demon
leaving well i didn't know that and it
was lovely
and then we had did the cake um i want
to start off today by
by saying that we we criticize
um these batman
villain uh billionaires that seem to be
running around our planet
being a billionaire now just seems to be
you get to do what you think is
cool like when you're worth a billion
dollars peop
it's basically just uh teenage fantasies
uh that you get to act out
but i will say something let hey
let's give credit where credit is due i
will admit when i'm wrong
about somebody truly
i've said negative things about jeff
bezos before on the show
we all know what's happening with
coveted in india jeff bezos
has decided to step in and help and this
is
this is amazing to watch let's play the
video
this is jeff bezos who's getting
involved to help
the people of india right now
and it's heartwarming all right here we
go
guys how exciting is this come on
[Applause]
i'm a bit confused but
those hats are very important for the
sun
[Music]
so he's what he's doing to help with the
coven in india
is he's uh uh letting people know that
you can be one of the very first to
buy the first seat on the new shepard
which is uh
his spaceship hey man
that's not nothing that is not nothing
and i think that it's high time we give
him his due
because it would be easy
to just step back and do nothing when
people are suffering in india
that somebody's dying like i don't even
know the statistic it's like every two
seconds or something crazy
and they're burning bodies in the street
and it is an
absolute humanitarian crisis
but to be honest
jeff bezos uh saying that you can buy a
ticket
to a rocket which will take you on a
tour through space
i do believe is a good use of i think
it's good
i think it's a good use of resources i
do and anyone that disagrees with me is
wrong
i'm a little sick of people not
appreciating this man's contribution
he's in uh what is one of these cars
he's in the new shepherd
no the car the rivian the rt-1 and
they're they don't make a lot of these
and he's in there with a hat and he's
showing people that very soon you could
get on the new shepard
who's in that car with him by the way
i guess his new girlfriend maybe
oh look at jeff
he's got people in the back with masks
on what's that about
what are you doing with a mask on in the
back of the rivian with jeff bezos
what virtue can you imagine that level
of virtue signaling
you're on the way to a rocket launch
with jeff bezos in the back of his
rivian car and you've got a mask on to
prove
what exactly is that person scared of
getting covered
are they scared of getting covered from
jeff bezos
on the way to a rocket lock can you
imagine explaining that to the people at
the urgent care
because i'm sure that's where they go
you know the urgent care yeah how'd you
get this well i was in jeff bezos's
rivian his what it's a car they make
very few of them
and we're on the way to see the new
shepherd the who it's the
uh the new shepherd it's the new space
tourism rocket that bezos
my boss jeff and uh i got covet
i was in the car and i got covered so
smart that they have the mask on because
it is a high risk situation
it's a high risk situation to be uh in a
car with a billionaire on the way to
uh rocket launch it's a real hotbed of
coronavirus in there
jeff bezos's space venture blue origin
said in a video released thursday it
will soon
begin selling tickets for rides on its
space tourism rocket called the new
shepard guys how exciting is this come
on bezos said
because people are getting bored with it
you know
and i'm not one of these people who's
always like we should not explore space
i get it it's just funny
sign up to learn how you can buy the
very first seat on new shepard
now do you think do you think because
obviously it's going to be for rich
people
but you know everyone's going woke now
so do you
think that they have to just for the for
to save face send up like a
spanish lady works in a laundromat and
blast her in his space
with the other space freak
multi-millionaires
like do they just take like a black bus
driver and say
you've won and she goes what do i want
and you go you're going to space
and she's going to be like what you go
listen
jeff bezos is uh trying out his new
tourism rocket the new shepherd yeah the
problem is
a lot of people bought tickets and
they're all pretty damn white
because white people are sick of this
planet they've ravaged it they've
destroyed most of it they're sick of it
they want to go somewhere else
point being we need it to look
more representative of america so you
have won it's like that thing you've
been selected
when you get those phone calls so
they're just they're i i want them to go
into the hood
and get like a thug [ __ ] and throw her
in the new shepherd
sitting next to whoever the hell is
spending money to go to space
it shows him driving across the texas
desert the remote location of the new
shepard launch facility
notably at the wheel of a rivien r1t
electric truck which is emblazoned with
blue origin signature feather
new shepherd is designed to carry as
many as six people at a time on a ride
past the edge of space with the capsules
on previous test flights reaching an
altitude of more than
340 000 feet 100 kilometers
the capsule which has massive windows to
give passengers a view
spends as much as 10 minutes in zero
gravity before returning to earth
the rocket launches vertically with the
booster
now i don't want anyone to get hurt and
we know that
but would there be something wrong with
a challenger-like explosion
killing all of the people
except the black bus driver and that
we're sad about that but like if if it
was just the usual suspects
people that have too much money and go
let's go to space
would there be anything wrong with
watching this thing incinerate
i don't think so the rocket launches
vertically with the booster detaching
and returning to land at a concrete pad
nearby
the capsule's return is slowed down by a
set of parachutes
before softly landing in the desert
shares of virgin galactic fell more than
three percent
after blue origin posted its video as
bezos's company
will compete with richard branson in the
niche space
sector of suborbital tourism
my favorite word now suborbital
tourism don't you want to see space
virgin galactic has sold tickets to 600
passengers at a price between 200
000 and 250 000 each
although the company expects it could
increase its prices substantially for
the first commercial flights
they will be and then bezos said we're
going to price them uh
competitively uh with uh where uh
branson is at so between two hundred
thousand a quarter million around that
area
is what it will cost to uh engage in
sub-orbital tourism
while the world literally burns beneath
you
that's what being a billionaire is now i
mean and we should be exploring space
but i think it's funny that immediately
we're thinking about uh ways to open
marriotts up
there and get people up there uh uh
in uh a completely non-educational
capacity
by the way let's take a space
cruise it's about that time
everyone is also being mean right now to
bill gates
who's one of our good friends they're
being mean to him
because he doesn't want to share his
vaccine patent
with the developing world
well i mean
have you ever been to a restaurant
and you're eating the chicken wings and
you go
what is in this
sauce i've done this and the waiter
looks at you and goes
we could tell you what's the funny joke
do you know it
you don't know it oh if we told you we'd
have to kill you if we tell ya
we'd have to kill you
this is this guy's hot wing sauce
this is his secret sauce
this is his flavor of the month mango
habanero glaze sauce and
no it doesn't get bottled up without his
say-so
he could tell you but he'd have to kill
you
you think bill gates was sitting around
cooking up this batch
so that people out there could just
take it and open up their own wing
stands
we think not and and i understand it
because you imagine a hot wing sauce
imagine if it was a vaccine
that could potentially save the lives of
of millions of people that are literally
burning their bodies in the street right
now
you would still say hey that's my
mother's recipe you can't take it
let's read a little bit of this bill
gates under fire for saying vaccine
formulas shouldn't be shared with
developing world
do you want to hear him defend himself
here let's
hear him defend himself because we are
too critical of him
i have always believed this guy had no
intentions
except the best intentions for humanity
that's why he wanted to shoot a missile
of uh dust at the sun
and uh why he uh you know he went uh you
know white water rafting with
epstein but he is
just about saving lives there's been
some speculation that the changing
intellectual property rules
um and allowing these vaccines as you
say
the the the recipe for these vaccines to
be shared
would be helpful and do you think that
would be helpful
no why not well there's only so many
vaccine factories in the world
and people are very serious about the
safety of vaccines
and so moving something that had never
been done moving a vaccine from
say a uh a j
factory into a factory in india that
it's novel it's only because of our
grants and our expertise that can happen
at
all the the thing that's holding things
back in this case
is not intellectual property there's not
like some idle vaccine factory
with regulatory approval that makes
magically safe vaccines
you know you've got to do the trials on
these things and every manufacturing
process
has to be looked at in a in a very uh
careful way ah i'll answer the real
answer
play her question again i'm gonna answer
his answer okay
there's been some speculation that the
changing intellectual property rules
um and allowing these vaccines as you
say
the the the recipe for these vaccines to
be shared
would be helpful and do you think that
would be helpful
list listen
listen i don't even know
what you think you're asking me right
now
okay here's a reality
there are these things called vaccines
they're tough to make they're not made
in a magical factory in the sky
okay they're made for profit
in a factory where i walk around with a
hard hat
and i goose people gender unimportant i
just goosed them
that's where they're gonna be made and
if you want one
you can spend a little coin okay
but other than that we're not gonna be
letting you
run around with our product all over the
developing world
we do that if somebody's pricking you in
sub-saharan africa
that is us okay
so let's be real clear about why i'm in
this business
it's to make a couple of bucks
you think tech is good money you think
finance is good money
you know what's good money the essence
of all
life that's what i've decided i got a
little
bored i got a little bored
at microsoft where do you work microsoft
right yeah i got a little bored there
okay so i decided my next business
venture would be
trying to control the essence of all
life
on this planet deciding how much of it
there is and where
it should happen okay so i'm not
interested in like
you know this isn't a potluck dinner
where everybody brings a vaccine
this isn't a firehouse where somebody
brings macaroni salad somebody else
you know brings a [ __ ] lasagna this
is a vaccine party
and it's at my house okay [ __ ]
he seemed a little flustered kind of
giving that answer
he didn't look as comfortable as he
usually does giving that answer
why doesn't he host snl
what's with elon musk all the time get
gates uh to host snl
elon musk clearly wants to spotlight
let's not give it to him
let's get bill gates to host snl and
they could do a fun
sketch about bill gates explaining
uh to an indian peasant whose entire
family of 72 people
has just been burned alive in the street
why he can't share the vaccine patent
it'll be a laugh riot
i think so can't you see that sketch
aidy bryant and bo and yang dressed as
indian peasants
crawling across the floor okay
talking to bill gates about the vaccine
patent
i can and why not
people are up in arms uh about this
bernie sanders what did sanders say
sanders was like hey
sanders sanders was start staunchly
against this
yeah he wants to share the patents
sanders like a good moral man yes
the huge concentration held by okay last
weekend senator bernie sanders called on
president biden to support international
efforts to suspend
patent protections for coven 19 vaccines
arguing that they're artificially
restricting
the world supply of vaccines and
preventing citizens of poor countries
from gaining access to a life-saving
product there's growing public support
in america for sanders position
a petition signed by two million people
was sent to biden urging him to back
a temporary patent waiver for the
vaccines
60 on the other side of the fence is
billy gates billy boy gates
who supports increasing poor countries
excessive accessibility to the vaccines
however
[Laughter]
you love that sentence on the other side
is bill gates
who supports increasing poor countries
accessibility to the vaccines
however
gates the great global philanthropy i
mean do they write did bill melinda
write these articles and send them to
the paper
gates the great global philanthropist
whose businesses are based on
intellectual property laws argues that
it's a bad idea to wait this is the guy
that they had to break up microsoft
because he wanted a monopoly he had a
monopoly he wants a monopoly on your
health
and when people like me said things like
that i was called names
argues it's a bad idea to waive patent
protections for covet vaccines and share
their formulas
with the world for the sake of achieving
a dramatic rise in their production
and distribution
he said it's a technical matter
there's a limited number of
manufacturing plants
and the safety of the manufacturing
process is of the utmost importance
hey there's a limited number of places
to do this
and we should keep it that way how about
how about trying to increase the safety
standards at the
shut up uh sir may i ask
could it be possible to increase the
safety standards
hey [ __ ] you i my question is just that
i know you're concerned that there's not
too many manufacturing plans could we
build those plants perhaps and
increase the safety standards get out of
my face
we hope every we we uh we hope that the
patents are
uh available but and this i truly
believe this is what i believe
if you are in india and you are
21 and you are healthy
i don't believe you should get
vaccinated
even if everyone you know has died
if you are in india and you are healthy
and you take the right supplements and
you work out
and you eat a high protein diet perhaps
carnivore
uh if you eat only meat in india which
you can't you're not even allowed to
right
right so if you're breaking the rules
and somehow surviving off a carnivore
diet and you are healthy
and you are 21 and everyone you know is
dead
still still
and if your 21 year old friend who is
also healthy
died i would i
i don't think you need to get it and i
hope that's not a firestorm
i hope that's not national news and i
hope that dr anthony thought she doesn't
respond to me at tim j
dillon on twitter but if he did that
would be fine
too i'm not just trying to get attention
here
i'm not trying to get atta a lot of
people accuse me all the time like oh
you're trying to get a 10 i'm not trying
to get attention
i'm just saying that the podcasting
world has made some news in the last
week
i don't think anyone should get the
vaccine even if you're
old and immunocompromised and
and you've had covenant and almost
killed you once
i don't think you should get the vaccine
i don't think anyone should get any
vaccine
ever and if if that's a national
news story and my name trends on
every social media site that's ever
existed then so be it
because that's what i feel do you
understand
so i'm saying that no one should ever
get a vaccine
okay ever
for any reason even if you are sick
and you have asthma and you are 700
pounds
and it's being offered to you for free
don't
get it at tim j dillon
instagram twitter timdylandcomedy.com
dates are on the on the tour page merch
is on the merch page
okay i'm not i don't want
this i don't want this controversy do
you understand
i'm just saying i don't believe what's
happening in india is actually happening
i believe it's fake i believe
they are faking this have you seen any
actual body i think they're just burning
wood in india to get attention
i'm not trying to be controversial
and increase my audience like that
what i'm trying to do is just
converse
so what is happening in india isn't real
and you should not get the vaccine
okay
other things i've noticed trans
child athlete i'm kidding that's the i
won't even even for the joke
even for the bit even for the bit we
won't
even though it's clearly an ironic bit
and many of my smarter
listeners realize that and and viewers
we can't even you know we can't even go
because you know what'll happen but
rogan is uh he doesn't mean
don't get the vaccine what do you think
he means
uh i i think he means that if don't be
nervous
you're such a [ __ ]
he he means if you're a healthy person
who's not around
other like other people should be like
fauci kind of agreed with him right with
fauci's comment in regards to
rogan where he said if you're in a
vacuum then that's okay then you
shouldn't get vaccinated
like fauci did indirectly kind of agree
with rogan right with this statement
i'll pull it up i'm not trying to do a
non-answer here
but
i think fauci was saying that he was
disappointed
uh that india would go to such great
lengths
to just try to get cheap vaccine from
billy gates
an icon and a great man
what if this happened okay what if saucy
showed up at rogan's studio and smacked
the [ __ ] out of him
on air like just beat the [ __ ] out of
rogan on air
we would all listen to fouchy fauci
should fight rogan yeah
in a jake paul style public spectacle
that's that's how to settle it
fauci versus rogan similar height
but different skill sets and let's see
what happens
the reason why this is fauci's quote he
said is you're talking about yourself in
a vacuum
you're worried about yourself getting
infected and likely that you're not
gonna get any symptoms but you can get
infected will get infected
if you put yourself at risk well
we support everyone and that's the most
important thing
if we support all of the people out
there that are doing all of the things
at every minute however you feel
whether you're a cop or you're a fat
girl with a knife
whether you are joe rogan or anthony
fausch
whether you are uh vaccinated or
anti-vaxxed whether you are bill gates
or an indian peasant who desperately
needs you to uh
remove the vaccine pattern we support
everyone we support everyone in all of
the things that they do at all the times
they do them
how often do you get the chance
to buy underwear from a man who is
dishonorably
discharged from the military from
murdering a child unprovoked
well today i'm going to give that to you
sheath underwear.com
sheath it's great as underwear as a
bathing suit it's a little pouch that
you can put
not little but it's a pouch to put your
[ __ ] and balls in
it helps you that you don't sweat and
chafe it is great
it has that moisture wicking stuff but
you don't get a rash
it is great sheath underwear dot com i'm
telling you the inventor robert patron
check out the story it's interesting
it's somewhat inspiring that a man
would come back from murdering civilians
and start a company where he sells
underwear
to other men because he's a tough man
that didn't have any gay experiences in
the military at all
he's a man that is tough that thinks
about sweaty balls
and shafts but he loves [ __ ] and there
was
absolutely no strange brokeback mountain
style experience
in the tents over there in fallujah do
not
think about it at all he's he's focused
mainly on the sweat of men's balls
sheath underwear dot com sheath
underwear dot com don't ask don't tell
they have there's a flexible pillowcase
for your chunks literally all i wear now
they're the best if you have to try it
yourself give them a google sheath
underwear dot com
do some research sheath the inventor
robert patron oh he just read this
whatever he's great he's a gay murderer
who killed babies in the military and if
that's not something you can't
can get behind then you're not an
american he
he loved going to iraq and sucking [ __ ]
and shooting people in the face and then
it came back
to make an underwear that keeps your
balls from sweating
so that when someone is sucking them
after they've murdered a family trying
to get information
uh which is what he used to do they're
all good
they love comedy sheath underwear not
you know one of these they're just gonna
go enough
maybe the gay thing one of them i keep
trying to find an angle where they drop
us i literally keep trying to do it it
can't happen
i keep trying to find an angle so i'm
going to call this guy gay now
for a few weeks to see if that'll do it
and then if that doesn't do it we'll
move on to something else
but this is a gay man who started an
underwear company
because he likes [ __ ] and he doesn't
like when it gets too sweaty he likes a
nice
uh dry [ __ ] he wants to make it wet
while he's blowing another soldier in
the desert
it's a love story it's good underwear
it legit is cheese underwear.com he
really is good underwear
we wear it and the guy who started it
really is a gay murderer
you know all things can be true both
things can be true
sheath underwear dot com you use code
tim to save 20
sheath s h e a t h underwear dot com
uh use the code t-i-m
thank you if you're a fellow who's
resting body temperature rivals out of
las vegas pavement mid-july standard
antiperspirants don't give you much
relief
this is really the best deodorant on the
market duke cannon dry ice cooling
antiperspirant is made for guys who run
uncomfortably hot it's perfect for you
if you work outdoors or indoors you're
working during the summer you're an
athlete it's moisture and friction
activated
cooling system is formulated with
menthol to give you an all-day sensation
of standing under an air conditioner
crank to high not a heat lamp stuck on
broil
available in refreshing menthol and
eucalyptus peppermint and musk sounds
what's good about this deodorant is that
it's not only you are dry but you feel
dry you feel cool
so that helps um with the highest level
of odor and wetness protection allowable
you'll last longer in the heat
and your t-shirts will too okay they've
got all kinds of products dry ice
cooling antiperspirant
um and you're gonna love it okay really
all you guys have to do
is uh go to dukecannon.com
d-u-k-e-c-a-n-n-o-n-dot-com
do canon.com and use promo code dylan
you get 10 off your next order
perfect if you're a lady and you want to
get something nice for your man
or if you're a dude and you're a woman
is a hulking beast
use promo code dylan for 10 off your
next order
you get free shipping with orders over
20. a curated collection of duke cannon
products are also available
at select target stores but i'm telling
you right now what's great about this
is it's got methyl to deliver instant
cooling it's enriched with activated
charcoal to remove toxins while
deodorizing
moisture and friction activated cooling
system that keeps you cool highest
allowable sweat protection
crisp peppermint and musk scent you're
going to love it it's the highest
allowable sweat protection
go to dukecanon.com and use promo code
dylan d-i-l-l-o-n
for ten percent off your next order
um let me let me just quickly with the
mckee brian tweet
my point about that tweet which got
everyone nuts was that fat children fat
teenagers
are looked at as threats as adults it
may not be right
i wasn't saying she deserved to die
because she was fat i said the cop made
a split second decision because he saw
the girl with a knife
uh uh charging another girl or you know
are about to thrust a knife into another
girl
which is a potentially fatal injury i
did not say she deserved to die because
she was fat
the fat activist movement came
for me again i don't remember the last
time they came for me
but the fat activist movement
uh has come for me and this is why i'm
actually trying to get in better shape
because
uh fat people at at one time were a
jolly sad
but jolly people meaning fat people were
sad
when they were by themselves but when
they were with others they had to
convince you that they weren't sad
and they were like it's fun we're having
fun i'm
f you know now fat people are like
they're like rude
and they're it's true
i don't want to be a part of this
community anymore because they've become
they've become like moralists and
they're they're
they're saying that fat is uh
like a mark of achievement or a mark of
virtue
that you should love your body no matter
what well maybe
i'm not telling anyone not to love
themselves but i'm saying you should
love yourself
uh within reason
do you see what i mean you shouldn't
just love yourself no matter what
there's got to be a point where you stop
loving yourself
there's got to be a line like body
positivity
is there ever a line where you're not
allowed to be positive about your body
there was a guy when i grew up he was
1100 pounds he had when he died
he had to cut part of his house out
and take him out they had to they had to
do a construction project
on his name was walters from long island
some [ __ ] person will find it
they had to cut out part of his house
to get him out of the house
did he really need to hear
that he was beautiful the way he was i'm
not saying it's necessarily always a
negative message
but i'm saying between
hating yourself because you're a little
you got some pudge
and needing to be cut out of a wall
is there a happy medium where we can we
can tone it down with the love of the
bodies
can we tone it down with the love of the
bodies here's the other thing about fat
people
fat people are pretending they don't
know they're fat
and they don't like fat people are now
acting like fat
has no negative health uh implications
and that it's just not harder to do
things they're like oh it's a
social construct not always walk
upstairs
that's not a social conscious it just
sucks
walking upstairs is hard
when i do it with him when i get to the
third of the fourth flight
i have to stop and pretend i'm saying
something profound
or pretend to notice something this will
be like oh you know what i just thought
of to just catch my breath
because i don't want to keep going you
know you're fat
you know you're unhealthy if you're a
fat person you know you're unhealthy
can you play lizzo's thing where she's
talking about the body positive movement
being co-opted by thin people
and i'm not saying if you're fat you
should hate yourself or you should be
unhappy with yourself
or you should be uh you know made fun of
or shamed or
we don't want any of that but people and
not everyone has to be uh
real thin but we need to calm down with
the
love of the bodies that are like
being broken lizzo said that the body
positive movement
was being used by people who who like
really like their bodies genuinely like
thin people
are getting involved and saying hey i
love my body and lizard's like
yes we get it everyone should love their
body but this movement is for fat
people and fat women of color
specifically it's on lizzle's tick-tock
yes here we are
and the thing with the mckee branding
it's a tragedy that she died
it sucks i'm very upset about it um
that anyone is that dies that anybody is
killed by the police or
anybody's in that situation um it it
it it's a tragic situation
but i was not thatched i was not saying
she deserved to die because she was fat
this is
this is uh this is insane
um what i was saying is that a fat
person wielding a knife i was 16
i was chubby not that chubby i i got
chubbier later but like
a fat person wielding a knife
it's it most people look at it and
they're
they're afraid you don't register as a
child
you don't register as a child when
you're a fat person unless
unless you're a chef
if you're fat and you have a knife
you have to be a chef and you have to be
preparing a meal
but in any other situation a fat person
with a knife is very scary
it's true i i don't i don't mean to
disrupt anyone's sense of reality but
it's not nice what happened and i don't
like it
but i also don't deserve uh to be
called out by the fat activists here we
are
would you wake up and trade places with
somebody who is on the heavier side
i'm glad she asked because this has
given me very much when that sociologist
dr
jane acts that room full of white people
raise your hand
if you want to be treated like how black
people are treated in this country
her raise your hand if you would wake up
and be black tomorrow and nobody raised
their hand
and that's because they know that
there's some systemic [ __ ]
that happens to black people that does
not happen to them and will never happen
to white people
that's correct so yes if i asked you
right now have you been shamed yes
you've been through a lot
yes it sucks being a person in this
society because we have to go through so
much to love ourselves
but would you switch places with a fat
person's body tomorrow
you would not because you know that
there is a whole system
that oppresses fat people that you do
not experience
experience wait a minute hold on the
system that oppresses fat people
don't know i look at the restaurants and
the portions and the servings and the
drive-throughs and i think fat people
are pretty well cared for in this
country
they're pretty well taken care of i
don't see the oppression of fat people
when there are fast food restaurants and
all you can eat buffets
and there's postmates and grubhub and
doordash
and people will literally show up to
your house and put a sandwich in your
mouth for you
i don't see fat people being uh
i mean literally there are shows about
food until there is a network dedicated
to food
there are countless instagram i on my
instagram
it shows me like hot dudes and and uh
nice houses
and then just those exploding desserts
you know those desserts that explode
it's very sexual it's like it's a dome
that's over it
they pour something on it and then it
just explodes all i see on instagram is
those desserts
so it's weird to me that she says
there's a system
that's against fat people but literally
everything from what you put in your
mouth to even what you
look at every day is to entice and
excite
fat people am am i wrong about that
i know that people go through things for
being fat i hooked up with a guy once
who did nothing but grab my fat and
scream
at the top of his lungs it was very
disturbing
he was grabbing and this is a fetish
that i found out people have
and it has to do with something in
childhood i don't know but he would just
grab my
fat and mash it together and he'd go
and it was off-putting at the time i was
trying to enjoy it
he was having fun with it but i
understand that that's what happens to
people truly
literally he was sucking my dick but
then he just decided to start mashing
my fat together and we went
i did that for several minutes but then
i read about that and that's something
that's
more normal than not normal
so what i'm saying is that i understand
what she's saying
but i also have issues with it continue
this
so let's remember body positivity yes we
want to end harassment and shame
but we also are working to dismantle a
system that oppresses fat people
what is that system that we treat people
though
this is what i'm curious about and i
genuinely want to be educated
i understand that fat people have it
tougher and some people
have medical issues and some people you
know are not it's not their fault that
they're
as fat as they are um
my mother used to complain because my
mother had a thyroid problem
my mother did she had a slow thyroid and
she would tell us that
all the time at outback she would say i
have a thyroid
condition she would tell us about it the
outback
and i know that that happens i'm not
blind to that
i get it it's not all
nurture some of it is nature my mother
would explain that to me
but continue i want to see the rest of
this oh that was all of it that was all
of it yeah just one tick tock 60 seconds
well that's okay i saw something else
but
it's it's uh we get it we we know where
we're going here
with that and i'm just saying that
i have a lot of love and respect for the
body but can we put on one of the really
big people that talks about fat phobia
and fat acceptance
let's put on because i'm trying to
understand the system that oppresses fat
people
okay so an f-bodied person
what the [ __ ] is f-bodied it's it's what
they identify as now
jesus [ __ ] christ's body um
now we're talking that you got trans ams
up there and i mean cars not
youtube relax f-bodied activist maybe
just put fat activist in ben don't start
getting [ __ ] fancy with your reddit
terms
let's get a fat activist here to tell us
what the deal is
test holiday but it's an hour i can't
it's too long
okay this is the difference between body
positivity and fat activism from nylon
go to this i'm interested i want to
learn
because this is another community the
gays have left me out and then these
people have left me out
should i do this i'll do this what do i
have to say everybody should be a
bowling ball
hi my name is virgi tovar and i'm the
author of you have the right i don't
have to [ __ ] fat people right
because that's my only problem but i'll
get on the board with everything else
because i think people should have to
[ __ ] me keep going
okay is this what it is if fat activism
is just forcing skinny people to [ __ ] us
i'm into that if that's if this is a
clever workaround
saying that you have to [ __ ] me or i'll
kill you because you're
uh uh that's fine if that's what fat
active because i genuinely don't know
what it is
so if it's just shaming thin people into
having sex with fat
people i am for that keep going
i talk about the differences between
body positivity
and fat activism or fat liberation
what i've found since body positivity
has eclipsed fat activism
is that positivity seems to be the
biggest
i guess demand of the movement the thing
is that positivity isn't
exactly a political resource so it's
important as we're
thinking about moving forward as a
political movement what do we really
want yes and in fat activism the demands
are pretty clear
okay body positivity doesn't have that
same and let's go with the focus
if they're going to be a part of a
political movement you need to know what
the purpose
of the vision and what the plan of that
is what is the plan an issue i have with
body positivity is that the face of it
becomes increasingly whiter straighter
and thinner the more that the movement
gains traction
right people of all sizes all shapes all
ages
all abilities all genders experience
body shaming
however right like when we're
consistently focusing on the people
who have the least experience with
structural
discrimination politically
we have to really focus on who is the
person who is
most affected by this issue we all
benefit
when we think about the person who is
having the greatest impact
third as body positivity
eclipsed fat activism the question of
the movement
kind of went from how do we create
more rights and a life free from
discrimination
for people of all sizes two
how do i love my body both questions are
very important but in isolation again
i need to know what fat activism is
because they're fat activists sometimes
if you lose weight
they get mad because you've betrayed
you've made them
feel worse by losing weight i am so
confused as to what this is because i
went on a rabbit hole about this after i
was accused of being fat phobic
imagine and i'm trying to find out what
fat activism is because i may be
for it do you understand i could be a
very powerful resource
there are a lot of there are a lot of
listeners out there and viewers and i am
for fat activism
as long as i don't have to touch another
fat person so let's find out what it is
i don't want to touch a fat person but
tell me what fat activism is because i
may
join it so we we may find out at the end
of this video you think let's see
question of how do i love my body is not
complete
how can we think about this not just as
an individual experience
but as kind of a collective one indeed
and the way that we do that is we sort
of start to think about
you know again who are the people who
are experiencing the greatest
impact of discrimination based on body
and when we kind of think about that
we expand our frame of reference and our
political power and our political might
beyond just one person to something that
can have this extraordinary ripple
effect on a cultural level
and finally body positivity and
finally queso
how great would that be if she goes and
finally
queso okay let's let's finish this
but i i'm still you haven't done what
i've asked i want to find out what what
fat activism is and this is not telling
me what it is
it's telling me it's differentiating
body positivity
from fat activism but i need to know
what fat activism is
i believe it is
that we cannot
here's what i think it is i think it's
that
fat people get to go around
killing thin people
which i'm not against per se
my only problem with overweight people
and i don't have any because i am an
overweight person
but my only problem with fat people is
that i don't want to i don't want to
have sex with them
because i feel like it's monique had
that joke two fat people
she had a great joke i'm trying to find
your [ __ ] you're trying to find my [ __ ]
let's just go to
uh uh let's get a fish sandwich or
something it's very funny
and and i'm just uh but i want to be
involved in the fat activist movement
while mainly spending my time with
with twinks who are kept on a treadmill
and stuffed with adderall
but only because it's i feel like that
someone needs to show them respect too
but we're not we've we've not been able
to find what if what fat activism is
it says we the plane seats need to be
bigger
and right and that fat people have to be
celebrated
and which is great and they have to be
undercover magazines
and things like that but see you're with
fat acceptance but go to
fat activism is what we want it's also
known as right here
oh okay and there's third wave fat
activism
you can't find one thing on youtube
about this uh it's mostly like dr rhonda
patrick clips rogue
who's not a doctor can we move on please
she's never seen a patient
i mean enough with her please what if i
told you that bitcoin is the future of
money now what if i told you there's
going to be an actual in person in the
flesh event this year
for focus exclusively on bitcoin and
then it will be the biggest event in
bitcoin
history now what if i continue to tell
you that the event was going to happen
in miami florida
on june 4th and 5th and that i tim
dillon was going to be there too would
you believe me it's true
tell them what they've won the bitcoin
2021 conference is happening folks it'll
be in sunny hot miami florida
june 4th and 5th of this year headlining
the conference will be jack
dorsey the founder of twitter chamath
plablau libla
tony hawk yep he's a big corner michael
saylor
the dude who takes billion-dollar loans
against his company to buy bitcoin
and nick sabo tim dillon will be also
considered a headliner if he does a good
job with his ad read i bet i won't be
but there will also be a whale day ahead
of the conference if you're rich well
you can go a well pass will be there on
june 3rd there'll be bitcoin-powered
arcade games
a massive art gallery with all the most
famous bitcoin artists
tony hawk's skating and a half pipe and
much more
an after party it's fun for the entire
family
bring the kids get them involved in
cryptocurrency
liquidate their college funds and buy
the coin the hell with your sick mother
take her out of the nursing home get her
cash and buy the coin
go to b dot tc slash conference to check
out the event
purchase your ticket and be sure to use
my promo code tim dillon
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n there is nothing in
the world more important than buying
bitcoin
not your kids not their schooling not
your sick
[ __ ] relatives not your stupid wife
with that [ __ ]
titty cancer what you need is more
bitcoin
who cares that some of the people in
your family can't eat
they'll eat soon and they'll eat the
coin bitcoin is the most important thing
in the world it'll never drop
and even when it does it just means
it'll go higher it's going to a million
that's what the winklevoss has said
listen to the winklevi
if your wife starts in you grab her
don't hit her
but grab her forcefully and let her know
that you're a man and say i put our
money in bitcoin because of the wiggle
bye
come learn about bitcoin and celebrate
life and freedom of the bitcoin 2021
conference
bring the kids bring the family if you
can afford to if not
leave them somewhere leave them at a
rest stop and come and learn about the
future of money it's b dot tc forward
slash conference and use the code tim
dillon
for 10 percent off your purchase
price magic spoon is a keto cereal we
all had it yesterday everybody loves it
it's keto friendly gluten free
soy free uh low carb gmo
free exciting news magic spoon has
released a super delicious new for
flavor birthday cake
open your own box build your own box
flavors
customize them fruity frosted peanut
butter cinnamon
it's like the sugar cereals you ate as a
kid with no sugar go to magicspoon.com
tim dillon to grab the new limited
edition birthday cake or a custom bundle
of cereal try today
be sure to use the promo code tim dillon
at checkout to save five dollars off
your order
magic spoon is great they use high
quality sweeteners
it is so much better than sugar they use
what that fruit extract
that they always use you know what it's
called what is it it's a fruit
it should be in the ad reading monk
fruit monk fruit yeah monk fruit
is what they're using not sugar that's
why it's a little pricey
but it's good if you were trying to get
rid of sugar and everybody is
that's the move go to magicspoon.com
tim dillon it's so tasty you feel like a
kid and now
magic spoon ships to canada wow
canada canada
so if you're in canada and you like
staying healthy or like feeding your
children healthy cereal
this is really great for the kids don't
get them addicted to sugar young get
them on the spoon so important
magicspoon.com
tim dillon gluten free soy free
keto friendly 140 calories a serving
shed your mouth zero grams of sugar
13 14 grams of protein four net grams of
carbs
i'm telling you folks it's changed the
life of everyone i know
if you want to be an olympian this is a
cereal you need to eat
don't you want to be in the olympics
what event would you do
golf you'd do nothing but i'd do
anything i wanted to
magicspoon.com tim dillon
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
okay so we we finally have
an answer for what is fat activism and
this answer i like
very much we're going to share it uh
with the audience
anyway so what fat activism is for me
um i've been thinking and about and
working on the question
what is for activism daily not very much
for the past of
25 years or so you know i still don't
have an easy answer
um and it's a question that i came to in
my master's dissertation
which was published as my book fat and
proud in 1998 which was ages ago now
and i returned to it for my phd which
was a four-year research project that i
finished last november
and during that project i interviewed
about 30 fat activists around the world
people of all different backgrounds and
perspectives many of whom
had decades of experience in fat
activism
and nobody gave me a consistent answer
about what it actually is
since they were chewing and so given
this it made sense to me that fat
activism can be absolutely anything it
just
really depends on the context i like
that and this makes fat activism really
exciting because
it means you can tailor it you can
tailor it to what you're interested in
yes
all the things that you enjoy or the
things that you're good at or your very
very specific moments in your life yes
and so i kind of thought that so if i'm
just being fat and
rude and nasty in the lobby of a hotel
because i've come down a few minutes
after the
the breakfast has ended and i'm really
giving it
to the people that work there and i'm
giving it to them good is that this
sounds like that is fat activism
well i like that if i throw a fit
an enterprise rent a car because the car
they gave me is what i consider to be
uh too small that is fat activism
i'm now coming around to this and
enjoying it
let's let's watch a little more
something really big like a street
protest that's the thing that most
people
think of as activism when i talk to
people about it or a letter writing
campaign that kind of thing
and it can be as small as a wink a wink
directed at the right person at the
right time yes
well that's that i that i like
what she's basically saying is we don't
need these street protests
where everybody has to walk and chaff
but a wink a well-placed wink
is fat activism wink
i will wink and make people
uncomfortable and i think that's a good
barrier of entry it's low so the idea is
that
a well-placed wink to the right person
is fat activism so let's say
okay if i and i've actually done this
right i've been in 7-eleven
and i was eating the big one the big on
is a cheeseburger that you heat in the
microwave
and you take it out of its wrapper and
i've been
with the big on in 7-eleven eating it
you know putting the pickles through the
condiment bar on the on
and squeezing ketchup on it and biting
it and if i choose to
wink at the cashier i'm engaging
in the important work of fat activism
let's see what else this is really
this is uh beautiful
and it can involve changing laws but it
can also involve having a conversation
with somebody
or wearing something good and sometimes
it's about
refusal of dominant cultural values and
sometimes it's really really ambiguous
some fat activists try and draw lines
about what
is and what isn't for activism but i
think that kind of ideological purity is
completely overrated
and i'm interested in those kind of
hybrids um that people develop for
themselves and kind of try and draw in
to
make livable lives um my fat activism is
a part of my daily life i don't put on a
uniform or an outfit or something
special to do it
right or go somewhere me too um it's
really embedded in the way that i think
about things
the work that i do the people i know yes
it's there in how i walk and how i talk
yes
and i don't see much separation between
activism
and life right um you could think of it
as a kind of consciousness
yes um sometimes i do stuff that's more
recognizable as activism
i make things magazines which are small
homemade publications okay like this one
which i have for free you can have a
copy afterwards if you want
and sometimes i write and publish things
like my book and i've
published stuff in well i'm on sitting
on the board for the
the fat studies journal it's an
interdisciplinary journal of body weight
and society there's a mouthful for you
how do you get into contribute to
books like the fat the fat studies
reader
and also our own beautiful fat studies
in the uk
which karina co-edited so i do stuff
that is
activism and sometimes my activism is
very
small and subtle can be something like
breathing
or thinking or um
hold on
this woman just said her fat activism
was the act of breathing
that she could just be somewhere
breathing and she's being an activist
isn't that isn't that sort of proving
that being fat isn't healthy
if breathing is activism
aren't you giving away the game there a
bit
if you look my activism sometimes is
very simple
it's not breathing or getting out of a
chair
doesn't that suggest
that being overweight is potentially
unhealthy i'm no doctor neither is
rhonda patrick
but i still think that there's something
about
breathing as activism that denotes
probably not the healthiest lifestyle
but again what do i know but all right
let's we we've had enough thank you we
get we
kind of get it now it's everything it's
nothing
it's breathing it's winking at people
whatever you want to do plus size models
sent death threats by fat activists
after dieting
this is what i like now this is what i
like
i like this i like a fat person
threatening to kill a another fat person
who's
started to get thinner that to me is an
interesting type of person and one that
i want to know more about
the person that rosie mercado who used
to be a size 24 and is now a size 12 to
still fat right good was told to jump
off a bridge and kill herself by people
with people who objected are slimming
down the 36 year old told tmz i got hate
mail
not so much from other models just fans
that hated on me
wow they hated the thought that i was
really public about my weight loss and i
was losing weight she lost more than 170
pounds
some people love being overweight some
people don't that's what she says
i think it's a personal choice but
people were not happy
they were sending her threatening
they were threatening they would tell
her to kill herself oh she was 410
pounds too
she was 410 pounds and then she got and
she lost 170 pounds well she's down to
170 now yeah no
go up oh wow
she's 170. wow good for her she went
from four no
no no no
no good for her no
you skinny piece of [ __ ]
she's a benedict arnold
there is a movement of fat activists
that do activism by breathing heavily
yes but
she's i can't believe you would say that
and be so heartless
the people that loved her as a 410
pound model
want her to kill herself and jump off a
bridge
because she's now down to 170.
the only reason i'm not afraid of that
is people are telling me to kill myself
anyway they're saying it now
let's just do quickly elon musk at snl
everybody's angry that
elon musk is hosting uh snl we'll do
this quickly
uh elon musk uh and miley cyrus
people are upset on the show they're you
know responding to his instagram stories
or whatever i read this article
i don't know why he's hosting the show
but i mean i'm not a huge fan of the
show and i don't know i mean they don't
like that he's a billionaire and
lord michael says a lot of money he's
got like half a billion and lorne's a
legend he deserves all his money but i
mean
you know i mean it's weird that you
could work for somebody worth half a
billion
and you're like uh talking about income
inequality
i don't know you think it'll be funny
you think elon's gonna kill it
i don't know i think elon's gonna come
in there and
light it up with satirical brilliance
i'm not exactly sold on that but i'm not
exactly a huge uh
i'm not it's not for me you know right
you said what do you say is gonna do
dogecoin scotch is gonna he might do a
doge father sketch
yeah what does that entail
i guess he's like you come to me on a
day when doge is we're pumping and
dumping the dogecoin
or something like that that sounds
horrible man
i hope it's better than that what you
just described was that your idea of
what a dogecoin sketch should be
well the doge father sketch what what
else would it be i don't know i hope
it's something else
that was horrific god
but you know
we'll see what happens maybe it'll be
better than uh we think
you know maybe and then miley cyrus is
on uh
musical guest what about they should
have done like ted
nugent just to really get everybody
going
just really get everybody going isn't
lorne michaels a kind of a republican
too
there's no way he's not a republican
wasn't he like friends with trump
whatever i don't know i could be wrong
elon musk it's gonna be interesting he's
gonna walk out there
musk is the second richest person in the
country
after jeff bezos yeah
snl was not available for comment well
we hope everything goes well for elon
and the
cast of snl we hope that they come
together to produce
the great show that we know and expect
every week
on saturday night which is up as our
show is opposite saturday night live
that's why we're a little you know
this is the saturday night live that we
hope that you care about but i
understand if you have to
switch over to watch uh elon musk
do the doge father sketch on saturday
night live i will not hold it against
you
you only one time though only one
time that'll be a fun after party huh
you think they're doing an after party
doing snl after party with elon musk
just walking around talking to
people on the show
he's got a lot of money
what if elon musk did an
entire they should do a rogan sketch
where like elon
like smokes weed and they got to have
somebody play joe rogue like have bow
and yang play joe rogan
and then have elon get high again
and say something about vaccines get
them all
that's what i say well you can use that
that's a free suggestion snl writer's
room you can have it and i won't get mad
i will be very happy
if you go with it and if you don't go
with it just know that you have angered
a
fat activist and i will
not be silenced
and now i'm going to go back to my
activism